Liam Payne reveals he isn't ready for
marriage
shades Harry Styles new music and one
direction it's amazing it the 23 year
old singer just dropped his first single
strip that down as a solo artist I had
my eyes upon the prize in watching
anybody else not staring too far from
his 1d roots the song is a mix of pop
hip-hop written by Ed Sheeran and
features some subtle shade throwing at
the band that launched his career you
know I used to be money gone for me for
one thing shade doesn't stop there
here's what Liam recently told music
choice about Harry Styles solo effort
I'll be honest with you it's not it's
not my sort of music so it's not
something I'd I'd listen to but I think
he did a great job of doing what he
wanted to do this songs more of a
different era ters something I listen to
I guess for the record Harry's
self-titled debut album is number one in
83 countries right now
[Music]
but back to Liam the new father also
opened up about the possibility of tying
the knot with baby mama and girlfriend
Cheryl Cole
the two welcomed son bear in March he
told the sons at Dan Wootton quote I see
marriage as more of a religious thing
and I'm not really a religious person so
I know it's not really in the cards for
me
[Music]